it's mine and it's beautiful and it's
amazing I actually grew up in the Virgin
Island so I went to school in st. Thomas
and in high school
good hair was anything that was fine a
curly texture something that was
manageable bouncy straight something
that was easy to maintain that was
considered good hair growing up in
Atlanta
everybody had a relaxer I don't remember
seeing anybody that had natural hair
there were a lot of kids that you know
wore braids and things like that but I
still believe that the relaxing process
happened before the braids I always kept
it really short and I would have friends
that say that felt like pubic hair for a
long time I thought my hair was really
ugly and when I was young for a guy good
hair was a low cut you know even Caesar
number one maybe you had the part with
the Nike sign on the back a little bit
of flavor but pretty much everyone had a
low cut for the most part everyone had
straight hair that was just the look
even if that wasn't their natural hair
your hair if it took you five hours to
straighten it you were gonna straighten
it because that's what was acceptable I
grew up being into like punk rock and
the skateboarding scene if you look at
all the cool skaters and you look at
those hairstyles at the time it was all
spikes Mohawks Mohawks and my hair could
never do it
I kept it buzz everyone would say every
time I'd get a haircut is like why are
you cutting these curls off and I was
just like I can't stand them my hair
history can be best characterized by
control trying to gel it down brush it
down put it into braids my mom is black
and my dad is white and my mom had a
really demanding job and will be gone by
the time I wake up most days and so be
left to my yeah taking care of my hair
in the morning and it was a total wreck
I remember going to school with so much
hair mayonnaise in my hair that I looked
at brain growing up good hair and what I
thought good hair wasn't what I was also
taught from I guess from a little bit of
my surroundings my family and some
friends was that good hair was when you
permed your hair you know so when I was
growing up I did purr my hair a few
times growing up my hair was really
short
like low on the top skin on the side
slowly my mom liked it she said it was
like neat clean in our society I think
hair represents a way to express your
beauty individually it can be a way that
you express who you are and how you're
feeling that day but it's also a way in
our society to kind of control at your
aspects of beauty I was always told
growing up that your hair supposed to be
straight I didn't have that perfect hair
therefore I was other by society just
with the hair that I have perfect hair
good hair when I was younger came from
when I used to watch TV or magazines or
films all of the hair would be long
straight and even when I was looking at
black women on TV they would always have
relaxed hair long hair
there'd be light skinned beautiful women
with equally beautiful hair that was
only beautiful because it was straight
my father--he growing up in seeing what
he's seen I mean I feel like there's
just this culture there that it's like
you have to have be groomed and kept and
you can't let what pretty much is you
grow out because I know it's seen as
almost wild it was reinforced through
the images we saw on TV it was
reinforced through the popular people in
school or the people guys wanted to date
you know you saw that manifests itself
in many ways and and I think today it
still whereas its ugly head in many
cases I feel like straight hair is only
considered good hair because that's all
you see so you see on ads so you see on
Billboard's so you see on television you
don't see really people that look like
me and when you do the hair straight
trying to date but with natural hair was
definitely a challenge because I will
get the guy that's like oh I love your
hair little straighter you'd be more
beautiful if your hair was straight or
if I wear my afro just like washed and
go
what is that so I think there's a lot of
different elements that make us feel
less secure or less confident about
wearing our natural hair people have
made assumptions by looking at my hair
that I smoke I'm a Rasta I listen to Bob
Marley like those assumptions are
frustrating I couldn't made it to having
longer hair right around the time the
Trayvon Martin case happened when the
verdict came out I was just kind of like
it really doesn't matter like how
acceptable you look to someone else so
you should just look however you want
what makes you feel comfortable and I
think there was a strong push for this
natural hair I really wanted to like
embrace that and embrace the natural
curls of my hair I definitely think that
part of the reason I went back to
curling was the natural hair movement
because when I Japanese straightened my
hair all that was really at my disposal
was gels and uses and things of that
nature which I felt was causing a lot of
thinning for me and didn't really give
me like the look that I wanted whereas
now there are pomades they are leaving
treatments there are sea salt sprays
like there are so many different things
that I can use now I have a 16 month-old
daughter and her hair is identical to
mine and I tell her her dad tells her
how beautiful her hair is it's thick and
it's full and it's long for her age it's
important that she sees a reflection of
herself in me so that is another reason
why you know I'm really adamant and will
continue to stay natural because I want
her to see herself in me and others
around her I have friends and family
members who went natural after having
kids just for that example and I want to
make sure that I'm showing and
expressing and illustrating that natural
hair is beautiful I think my hair has
taught me in this society and world to
just be unapologetic people are gonna
love it and then people are gonna
[ __ ] hate it people are gonna see you
as unprofessional sometimes and people
are gonna have all these ideas in their
heads about whether and like what kind
of person you are I feel like my hair
has taught me about the importance of
confidence and individuality
I feel like black woman's hair is
political but is also not in that it
will always be in certain professional
settings
if you have your hair become afro that
there may have put up be a problem or
that you'll go into certain spaces and
people will try and touch your hair or
say something derogatory about your hair
I often think that my hair came out of a
lot of unwanted struggle like that sense
that nobody loves you you're useless you
don't have them contribute and like my
hair is kind of like that reclaiming of
like nag or like I'm here to take up
space you're gonna look at me like it or
not and unless you're gonna love it I
think in America and living in our
society a lot of people tell you what is
normal for your hair in the 80s you
wanted to have big frizzy curly hair
trends change with your hair and the
only way to I think you truly happy with
your hair is to embrace what works for
you the final works for you and for me
my hair represented who I was and my
personality and as I grew older I got
more comfortable with my body and got
more comfortable with who I was as a
person and I wanted my hair to reflect
that your hair is beautiful I've lived
the straight hair life it was cool but I
think that the way that you are
naturally will always be more beautiful
I think you shine more when you're in
your natural self my hair just taught me
to embrace myself to love me the way
that I came the way that I was created
and the way that I am right here wrong
off it's not bad to appreciate other
cultures but it's also good to embrace
my own and that's what my hair is too of
me I'm just so happy that girls nowadays
have different kinds of role models to
look up to and I think it's also
important that you can be versatile one
of the fun things I love about my hair
is that tomorrow I could wake up being
like I really want it to be straight and
I can make it straight so it doesn't
have to be any one thing from day to day
year to year or throughout your life
people are constantly changing and
evolving and
we're allowed to do that I would say
find her tribe find her crew and it
wasn't until I found my pack of strong
independent people that embrace their
curls that I felt like oh I could run
with these people because they are me I
think now good air is whatever you want
whatever it makes you feel the best when
you walk out the house is good hair for
me this is good hair for me for someone
else it might be a low cut whatever when
you walk out the house you feel like
you're on point you sell your confidence
is blooming
that's good hair
[Music]